لكل منا حلم حاول تحقيقه بشهادته العلميه
فكلما ارتفع مستوى التحصيل العلمي يفترض
ان يزيد العائد المادي والاجتماعي ووفقا
لتقريرا من جامعه جورج تاون فان حاملي
درجه البكالوريا سيكسون 84% اكثر من
الحاصلين على شهاده دراسه الثانويه فقط
ومع ذلك فان 44% من جميع الباحثين عن
العمل من حمله الشهادات الجامعيه يندمون
على مجال دراستها وذلك لوجود اختلاف مذهلا
في الاجور بحسب مجالات الدراسه الصحافه
وعلم الاجتماع والاصالات والتعليم تصدرت
قائمه التخصصات الجامعيه الاكثر ندما
بينما شعر بالرضا اصحاب تخصص علم الاجرام
والهندسه باعتبارها من بين الاعلى اجوره
على الرغم من ان الطلاب يجذبون الى مجالات
معينه اثناء وجودهم في المدرسه لاسباب
تتجاوز الراتب والامن الوظيفي الا ان
الواقع يتحدث بعد التخرج ويصبح فكره اكثر
اهميه وهذه اكثر 10 تخصصات جامعيه دي
مخرجوها عليها بحسب استطلاع ان الراي
والصحافه تتراس هذه القائمه كذلك علم
الاجتماع والفنون والدراسات العامه
وحتى من درس في مجالات الاتصالات والتعليم
واداره التسويق والابحاث نادمه على ذلك
العلوم السياسيه ضمن هذه القائمه ايضا
وكذلك علم الاحياء واللغه الانجليزيه
فسيختلون الان علوم الكمبيوتر او اداره
الاعمال بدلا من ذلك وفقني موقع يزبك فان
متوسط عائد هذا التخصص سنويا يبلغ
100,000$ تقريبا وهم الاسعد بشكل عام وعلى
كل حال سالنا الناس هل ندمت على اختيارك
لدراستك ومهنتك وما البديل الذي تفضله لو
عاد بك الزمان الى الورق
[موسيقى]
كثير بالنسبه للدراسه قعدتي 17 سنه ندرس
وفي الاخر ولا يتعين بشهادتي ولا استفدت
بيها باي حاجه غير في حاجه واحده بس وانا
رايح اتجوز انت معاك ايه معاك
[موسيقى]
دراسه فيها ثاني يعني لو رجعت ثاني للزمن
هاكمل دراسه فيها ثاني وهشتغلها ثاني خالص
يعني لما تخرج وكده معه التدريبات
والحاجات ام الكورسات اللي انا المفروض
اخذها فانا المفروض ان شاء الله هنلاقي
وظيفه حلوه ومستناني بمباراه
انا همم اختار الدراسه
وبعد كده المهنه
لان الدراسه هي اللي بترفع البني ادم وهي
القيمه الاولانيه يعني في الحياه
انا حبيت المهنه دي والحمد لله ابدعت فيها
عملت حاجات جميله قوي
الدراسه انا ما شفتش نفسي في الدراسه عشان
كده انا افضل مهنتي يعني انا بحب مهنتي
وبفضل مهنتي تماما الحمد لله على الوضع
الحالي
ولو رجع بنا الزمن باذن الله برده هاختار
اللي انا فيه لان الحمد لله رب العالمين
همم انا ما كنتش متوقع لنفسي كده
والحمد لله يعني تميزت فيها
الواحد عنده واحد همم ان هم قدروا يوصلوا
لنا الحته دي بس بعد كده بقى انت خلاص
[موسيقى]
وياخذ خطوه عشان يدور
على كل حال الحديث تتم وتتم معك يا طراد
بسامبل من جده مستشار تطوير الاعمال يسعد
هالصباح اولا اهلا بك صباح العربيه
وضيوفنا كمان خطيرين مثلك تراب اليوم هل
الندم في التخصص الجامعي لدى بعض الاشخاص
هو مرتبط بقصر النظر لما قد يخدم مثلا هذا
التخصص في المستقبل ماذا
عوده على التقرير والكلمه الجميله
شفتي العامل المشترك بين الناس بين 80
والناس اللي مبسوطين حتى لماذا درسوا انا
بحب اللي انا بعمله هي كلمه قله ادفيني
انا احبه الي انا مستمتع فيه سؤال عشان
يكون اثبات هل ندمت انك درستي اعلام انا
درس الصحافه واعلام لاكون مذيعه اخبار
سياسيه وفي مكان مرموق مثل العربيه وهذا
ما حصل
هل انت طبعا لا عشان كذا بنقول انت حبي
انت هذا الشرف تكوني فيه ودرستي كنت فيه
مشكلتنا الكبيره جدا وهذه رساله لمعاني
وزير التعليم تنادين 50% من 40 الى 50% من
الناس اللي تخرج وشهادات جمعيه يعملوا في
غير تخصصهم الدراسي او ما يكونوا حابينه
والاربعين في المئه ولا 60% الباقيين اكثر
من نصفهم ما هو مبسوط هو بيشتغل بشهادته
ليش بيحصل الجاب هذا نبيل الان عندنا
مبادره جميله من وزاره التعليم انهم
بيحددوا مسارات الثانويه العامه في مزارع
علمي في مسار ادبي في مسار مهني في مسار
مثل الجهاب اليسار لو يعني ولو هذه
المبادره الجميله
سارت زي ما بصير في دول متقدمه جدا
التقييمات الشخصيه للطلاب والطالبات انا
بتوصلني رسائل من اباء وامهات بيقولوا لي
ابناءنا متوترين جدا مطلوب منهم يختاروا
تخصص مهو عارفين كيف
يختار تقيمات علميه تقول لك ابنك عنده
ذكاء من هذا النوع ينفعني ينفع شفت الشابه
هداك اللي يقول لك انا مبسوط مهنتي متخيل
اللي انا وصلت فيه الان حد نقطه جميله جدا
يعني وتوجه لا يرغب في حياته
للاسف هذه من اقصى واصعب الاشياء اللي
صايره في المجتمعنا اولا الاباء والامهات
الاب ما صار دكتور يبقى ابنه الدكتور
الامه صارت مهندسه تبدا ابنائس المهندس
الحاجه الثانيه الاصدقاء يعني معظم اختيار
التخصصات يا والدين يا اصحابي داخلين
الجامعه الفنانين رايح معاهم انت مين انت
ايش ايش تحب
شخصيتك انت بصمه مختلفه عن اي احد في
الحياه الحاجه الثالثه المتاح يعني يجي
يقول لك والله قدم ايش تبغى تطلب في
الجامعه اضغط يقول لك حط الاختيارات
الثانيه ايش احط لك طيب هندسه فنون طب انا
انسان يناسبني طب يعني ما ينفع تقول لي
ايش تخصصات ثانيه وبعدين تقول لي والله
خلصت طيب يلا روح غير حياتك عشان ما عندنا
الادايه تدخل فيما اروح ادور في مكان ثاني
فهذه نقطه جدا خطيره
هل اليوم صار توجه الجيل الجديد انه كيف
بس بدي اعمل مصاري اكثر مش ضروري اكون
ماشي بالمجال التخصص اللي انا بحبه
شوفي هذه النقطه عشان الكل احد يقول بدي
مصاري اكثر وهو عنده مشكله عنده مشكله في
اداره المال وعنده مشكله في مثلا في
تصرفاته في المال فلما يتعدى الوضع المادي
هيبدا يشوفها الان في المكان الصحيح ولا
لا هل انا في المكان اللي احبه ولا لا
والدليل على ذلك في ناس كثير في مجالات
كثيره يعني شغالين ورواتبهم جدا عاليه
وعندهم في مستشفى من اكثر القطاعات الصحيه
في المملكه وحاطين عياده نفسيه الى
الاطباء
من كثر الضغوطات اللي هم فيها مع انه
رواتبهم من الاعلى اجرا الموضوع المادي
يجيء في المرتبه الرابعه انت تحتاج انك
تكون في المكان الصحيح في البيئه المناسبه
مكاني كبير انا عارف اكون قبل هذا كله هل
انا في المكان اللي يناسب نوع ذكائي اللي
يناسب شخصيتي نادين عشان لا ن- نلقي
باللون كله على الوزارات وعلى الجهاز وهذه
نقطه جدا هامه لكن انت الان مسؤول ادخل
اون لاين اكتب الذكاءات المتعدده شوف ايش
نوع ذكائك وا اللي ممكن يناسبك يعني انا
مثلا تخصص اما اختبارات تخيلي بكالوريوس
وسبعه سنين دراسه هي خمس سنين بعد 10
سنوات تخبط الين ما اكتشفت ذكاء لغوي انه
ايش ينفع
ينفع بالتعاود ينفع بالمبيعات والتسويق
كلها بدات تختص فيها وسعيد جدا والحمد لله
داخل بيكون افضل من الواحد يتخيل صفقه
واحده تعادل رواتب سنه فانا باقول لاي شخص
الان جالس يقول الجانب المال بالجانب
المادي طب انت اصلا ما انت في المكان
الصحيح اللي انت ممكن تعمل منه جرد ما بدي
اكبر لو عرفت نقطه ثانيه نادين ان هي
ميزانيه وهدرك كبير في ميزانيات الدول
التعليميه لما انا اجي اقول والله 50%
يدرسوا جمع بعدين يخرج يدخل في تخصصات
ثانيه كم مليار جلسه تصرف فيه احنا عندنا
في السعوديه في مكافات والله انا اجيب شخص
واا اشغل مكان ورواتب موظفين وكهرباء وفي
النهايه نصفها يروح كم مليار راحت معه
فكيف من الممكن يعني بتبدا الشركات
ويستخدمه التقيمات الشخصيه اللي تساعد
الناس على كل حال احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر
على كل هذه المعلومات من جده مستشار تطويل
الاعمال بسنبل واذهب الى زميلتنا رشا نبيل
كتير متفاعله معنا يعني كمان تراد بحب انه
يعرف انه رشا كنتي كل الوقت
نغير ثقافتنا في المنطقه العربيه عشان
يتطور التعليم بشكل طبيعي يعني احنا
كموهات ما يفضلش ابننا لازم نجيب ايه بلاص
في كل المواد لان ما فيش حد في العالم
هيبقى شاطر في كل المواد باختلاف انواعها
ما ينفعش واحد يبقى شاطر في المات- بيجيب
ايه بلاصه في الساينس بيجيب بلاصه وفي
السوشيال ما فيش احد كده لازم نترك الحريه
لاولادنا شويه اهم حاجه يبقى عندهم لغه
ويبقى عندهم شخصيه نفسيه متوازنه
كنت بالمواضيع الادبيه لغات وجغرافيا
وتاريخ ايه بلاس بس اصلا
رجعوكي على ده بس بتحبي قصدمك بالخبر
بتقول الدراسه انه الصحفيين اكثر ندما على
اختيار تخصصهم شو رايك بها نتيجه الماعز
المهنه بتاعتنا متعبه جدا جدا فيها هي
فعلا مهنه البحث عن المتاعب احنا فعلا
يعني الناس بتعتقد ان مهنتنا فيها بريق ان
نادين طالعه باناقه وبشكل حلو قوي لان ورق
الكواليس
الصحافه مهنه شاقه فعلا